welcome to this video round 10 of the
candidates tournament this is the video
for the game aronian playing right
against to par love ya Aronian is
trading leader viana now by one point
and it's in fact a bit more than that as
he has lost the individual encounters so
he basically needs to get one and a half
point more out of the remaining games
then we she does so he really should try
to win games the other hand to pull off
is basically out of it is on minus two
after having lost two are not in the
round before that so yeah pretty much
yeah well something like a freeroll for
to borrow he can only win in this game
but yes no pressure really whatsoever
well Aronian certain he wants to do
something let's see sloth defense no
this a surprise from to paula Fiamma he
had played it before of course it's not
like a revolutionary opening for him but
maybe something sharper could have been
expected yeah well maybe he's also
saying okay I'm building up a solid
position and I know the other guy needs
to come up to me anyway very often this
is a good good way to even play for win
to set up a really solid position not a
very sharp position and knowing that
your opponent will come after you very
often a good good strategy that some
people don't think of just try to win by
doing not so much can can be very
effective let the other guy bang the
head against the wall okay it's playing
them chobani ankles la the a6 laughs
very flexible opening for black and in
opening that I also have played numerous
times I always like that it's a very
very flexible way to play you don't
commit yet what to do in the center you
can supply
g6 e6 bishop out now there are many
possibilities but the right of course
has a wide choice now Aronian played the
most III which is a bit of a
conservative choice but ok well there
are many many possible lines I have for
wider I played g3 in this position quite
like ramnik did in the round what is
wrong date and quite sure again stunned
reckon you only gotta draw that game but
at a pretty pretty good position in the
early part of the game yeah well III
conservative as it blocks in the bishop
but of course you need to think about
your poor Nancy form if you for example
play an aggressive-looking move like
Bishop g5 black can even take
immediately here and aronian has lost
the game with that horribly against loop
McShane while ago well so III it's safe
but not it's not passive I'm not saying
that but it's so rather conservative
yeah now black has a number of moves
available until tomorrow plays Bishop f5
which is enjoying a pretty good
reputation nowadays it's a very
comparable to another line that I'm like
to show you because it is important for
this game this line is well known for
for ages and also believed to be
relatively solid for black what we got
in the game for instance this and this
can be played yep in the game just look
at this we get a very very similar
position but pawn on a six and set up a
six so it's pretty clear that a six is
the more useful move compared to to a
six so that's a question if white can
use it in any
in any meaningful way um aronia now
played the move Bishop b3 again
relatively conservative choice why done
can try other things here that yeah that
are also very solid for black not going
to donate going to exaggerate here but
let's say Bishop e2 or Bishop d2 are
interesting to sort of prevent prepare
that try to get the bishop pair and at
least have some some idea how you're
going to win yeah with the two bishops
in this case it's still very very solid
for black and black does not even
necessarily need to play e6e can also
play move like h6 to secure secure this
okay Bishop d3 and now the part of just
took yeah probably okay in the smooth in
the very very recent book only released
our like I know two weeks ago it's like
a Liam top Grandmaster and top
theoretician borissov rock is also
looking at this line from black mostly
from the black perspective and he
recommended bishop g6 and in this book
just saying that black can keep this
this tension and shouldn't exchange
immediately um and he's giving a reason
for his avoidance of the exchange and we
will see that exactly in the game yeah
this is exactly his line and very
understandable moves Bishop b4 is simply
designed to prevent Iran and this is
essentially the only idea that white has
in this position pushy for to get some
some to make some progress in the center
keeping a space edge there Bishop t two
castles and rook everyone exactly this
move rogue ft one is the end
of them of the paragraph in this
mentioned book the a brooke says sentir
white is slightly better AIT explains
also why black is so slightly worse
compared to the other position right
here black can is faced with with a
tactical with the technical trick what
is the most normal move on this position
for black gap I'm sure you would agree
that night bd7 looks completely
completely normal now developing the
last piece to the only square available
unfortunately this falls to a very
typical technical trick and this is my
txt five very useful trick to know get
this on the board quite often in in in
this line in case you mu can come to
this this type of position yeah night
xt500 funny trick simple is that check
just winning of course an important
central pawn so when Bishop e2 is easy
what happens if black captures here okay
then I'm taking before the bishop is not
protected that's all so easy this is in
fact the the tricky move it takes and
now the important thing is that after
Bishop takes d21 can take only six and
this is the only important point the
night on this happiness attack now is
dulla tech and black will save one of
the pieces and then again has suffered
yeah and had some as a lost upon and
will suffer in this position yeah this
is basically a fluke statement you
cannot play the normal move Knight bd7
and need to react somehow to this issue
of the bishop he says retreat protect
exchange yeah changes looking
unattractive so to Paula played a 5 and
this way of course he has simply this
Bishop covered
ok so this some information about the
opening and the typical ideas he
retreated to e7 and now white push
deform yeah this position time is
certainly also what I broke referred to
as being slightly more comfortable for
white yes I would agree i mean if
anybody white is certainly enjoying a
slide plus on the other hand it's clear
that black is not going to be in big
trouble anytime soon he's got a very
solid position and it's not so easy to
see how wide is going to make any
progress rook e8 Quincy 226 all this
looks perfectly perfectly normal um what
I'm not so sure of actually is what
aronian should do in the next couple of
moves simply because rather quickly I
think black gum gets very very
satisfactory position and I don't really
know how to improve for YTM I can show
you what he played played rock d3 this
is also very normal and logical looking
movie prepares a doubling on the default
in cases opens that is rook be three I
don't really think this can be can be
really a bad move but it is it seems
that after only a couple of moves black
ass equalized I can show you how it
happened Rock d3c five yeah directly
attacking the center this is in fact a
very concrete way to approach things I
don't think that this would have been my
absolutely first idea the position
simply because of this d5 possibility
but it seems after Bishop f6 that black
has a perfectly active positioner and
this
does not lead to anything much for what
if we look at this he played now aronian
did route 81 we can look at alternatives
here what if white takes only six for
example a black can take with the Queen
and it's not the parent how he's going
to be be punished let's say for his
quick opening of the center sometimes
you cannot play those quick text on the
center when you are in a static Ram
position but because you're not well
enough set up so that but here it seems
perfectly all right I mean you can kick
the Queen ear but it goes to c6 and
black ass is very nice Bishop it
shouldn't be any any kind of problem so
Luke d1 was played not yeah it's
perfectly logical again intending to
take black can of course not take on be
two witnesses very easy or this
alternatively is also also leading to to
trouble now with this attack blackwell
even loose check check lose two pawns
back so on pieces one down it's a clear
that black cannot take but here yes a
very good way to play can take I did
that take rook take and night to evade y
and trust glance you think okay maybe
White has a little something and yeah
well what has the the default nicely
occupied and those pawns there on dark
squares with the dark squared bishop so
white maybe can in the distant future
play against those pawns but but
short-term black has the idea night is
six to deform and this is a very
important resource of course it turns
out that this seems to be perfectly fine
for black aronia now played them look 12
d 2 yeah
no is there something else we should be
five maybe a move that could could have
been considered trying to get rid of
this Bishop look 132 also had some
slight technical problem to it yeah
maybe maybe this was a was an
interesting try it even simplify
simplify the position more of it yeah
but still rip dajon there's not much
happening really black is perfectly
solid yeah in the game rook T to note
that this is weakening the back rank so
if white should accidentally touch
tonight in his rookie one mate so I'm a
very important counterplay no 96 now
this is the point no Aronian played loop
to d6 and after that I think it's it's
over in terms of any kind of try for an
edge there should be three is probably
what needed to be played but after you
create black still feels very solid but
I think you needed to do that Aronian
after after this route new stance Queen
c7 and now it's getting really forced
the bishop is attacked you cannot go
here this lose this material instantly
this exposed rook yeah this is what was
played rookie 6 it's not leading to
anything here black is very comfortable
with the strong Bishop Bishop 33 yeah I
now of course like puts the night to
deform yeah and here's one of those
cases you shouldn't touch the night and
checkmate along with a lot of the mate
so you you needed to go here
nothing else covering the back rank now
Queen e7 was played yeah Black has
certainly equalized hear that that I'm
sure of and it's even white who needs to
be a bit careful I mean it's not rocket
science to do to find the defense sir
but so you need to be a need to be
cautious to not get into trouble age
three important don't want to get mated
root d8 yeah now aronia decided to to
simplify matters here yeah cause tupelov
took with the pawn you won't you want
the passer they form a form is an
important roof I think it blocks this a
five point on a dark square and actually
gives white some distant hopes because
if you just for example would look at
this position and just look at it
without any heavy pieces queens of rooks
off and with that white actually would
have serious chances to do something
because he could actually get the King
here and play against those pawns so a
for as a board as it fixes a pawn on a
dark square and this is good for the
pure bishop endgame h5 gaining space
yeah idea to parlay to play them and
move that he probably weakened that you
regret it also in the press conference I
think he played the g5 very active me as
usual is not the kind of player who um
yahoo's who's doing nothing and the
funny thing is that he said that he
overlooked White's reply which is quite
funny it took 10 minutes and he didn't
think of rookie to which is quite quite
amazing but it sometimes happens you you
don't look at the most obvious
possibilities if why the
yeah would have been forced Nala 22
don't play rookie to the only was this
move and listened in fact looks a bit
scary with the big back rank there is no
tactic or anything quickly happening but
I understand that the part of was
attracted to that but after rookie to
Queen moves Bishop d to the bishop has
gone to position where it's actually
quite useful always looking at the FI
phone and now black in a way has played
g5 which does not really help him but
it's mostly a point that white can
attack still like is perfectly ok here
is just too active you know everything's
very normal and now Queen a free plate
boronia and getting the Queen's off yeah
here you could think about other moves
but really the only real hope for white
is to somehow get the Queen's off get
the King to d3 and play this end game
this would actually be really
comfortable so I understand very much
that he played the Queen a 3-2 exchange
Queens um you can also could have played
young other Queen awesome let's say here
Quincy for this was also an idea it
probably forces Queen 2xg for and now
the question is what is blacks best
setup you can push the King up to g6 and
prepare five to get rid of this G for
porn I can also go with d3 I think you
should combine this actually maybe just
to illustrate this kind of line could
have happened check and now a bishop
move anywhere somewhere this is actually
very similar to the game it's just a
different porn structure um I don't
really think it makes much of a
difference black is far too active there
two were to allow y term anything
anything substantial quit h5 was also an
idea
but this is in fact is answered very
funny move Queen c2 that's not funny but
Bishop g5 Queen back is quite funny I
think just tempting while to take and
then set up this this kind of pin after
F for d3 it's black with the slightly
better chances on the deep one is very
dangerous and this is a kind of a
strange configuration yonder on the King
side yeah okay this is not something
that white should try and queen of three
I think as service make sure makes lots
of sense yeah now we get this end game
as I managed as I mentioned before here
King it too was also possible but black
will always play d3 of course in the
game we get to go to this position and
here of course this is the only
important point but of course form for a
good player it's pretty much an
automatic move black must play g3
obviously you cannot allow white to to
go to d3 at least in my book going to
pull off took three minutes to to check
things but um you must do that move
simply if you do if you play what else
what else even though I don't know we
should hear something I that's a stupid
Hanks g5 let's say nothing move and then
I'm going here and now the problem is
simply that i'm going to make progress
and at the entity for will be a weakness
simple as that the ideas if you just
stay put yes like I you don't have
anything active anyway just just to show
the idea then at the end there will be a
4k yeah somewhere so and now I'm trying
to attack deform and I can attack it
three times with the rook the bishop end
with a king that's the point and black
will not be able to defend that so this
is why you absolutely must play d3
there's really no way around it and this
is oops what to polish
let's check and put the bishop to reform
maybe at what i believe is actually he
he pretty much instantly decided to play
d3 but probably calculated a few moves
beforehand okay rook g4 and f6 we now
see that can this f form business is
also happening just like i showed in the
line before but the difference is of
course that this point is advanced and
cannot be attacked in any way by white
skin yeah and after check these moves
they settle for a draw there's really
nothing to do here for both sides um
black cannot really play for a win as
the d3 porn will get vulnerable to too
easily which means i mean you always had
to have to keep the rook there and white
absolutely cannot do anything as well as
he always needs to guard the d porn so
draw is a very young very fair and
logical outcome here yeah how to
evaluate this job certainly a bit
disappointing for Aronian not that the
polyp is an easy guy to beat but yeah
you only have five chances left and
aronia needs to win games to to even
have a chance to catch up and well he
didn't come anywhere near win in this
game it simply was very solid this
position that the pile of head out of
the opening despite a brooks assessment
of white being slightly better i
certainly believe that it should be
possible to conserve some sort of slight
advantage but okay I couldn't put in the
time to really figure that out aronian
also couldn't do it over the board as we
as we have witnessed okay this means
that aronian still has slight chances to
catch honor but it certainly needs some
lost by the she in one chance of missed
in the game next round when
on his black against crumbling and
aronia needs to win I don't know against
whom is playing but he needs to win know
of no way around it I think this clear
winds are necessary yeah I hope you
enjoyed the coverage for this game
thanks for watching